this thing does not look safe at all I
still want to write it
with over 17 million hits online Colin's
high-flying Hoverbike became a web
sensation colin has propelled himself to
the number one spot and his neighborhood
better watch out
we've hooked up with Colin at his UK
shed of operations to find out more
about this most marvelous of flying
machines I've never flown so I thought
let's have a crack at that you know what
put a video out asking people for ideas
so the hover bike was born one of the
most difficult things was learning to
ride it really the eyes got a mind of
its own the old hover bike so you kind
of just you're just trying to tame it
basically when you're on it it's
probably like trying to write a line
flying lion yeah that's what it is
flying lion so how did Colin build his
flying lion Colin needs to build a
machine that has enough power that it
can lift his weight and the weight of
the machine itself to accomplish this
he's used paraglider motors power motors
are perfect for this because they have a
large power-to-weight ratio because
normally they're designed to be mounted
on someone's back but colin has bounded
them so that they point down and push
him up into the air each motor has 27
horsepower that creates a lift of 150
pounds or 70 kilograms since call weighs
176 pounds or 80 kilograms he needs two
of these motors to get him off the
ground if Colin were to mount both the
motors in the same direction it would
cause their combined rotational force to
rotate the hover bike so he's done as
he's flipped one upside down and now
he's created another problem because
he's generating lift towards the ground
so he has to change that blade out for
another one because propeller blades
only did rate lift in one direction
once up in flying how does Colin control
where the bike is headed the engines the
frame and Colin are just below the
lifting capacity of the hover bike so he
can't add steering he can't add a seat
and he can't add stability controls this
means that the only control mechanism
that colin has left is moving his own
body weight around and he does this to
move forwards and backwards and
side-to-side and sometimes more
successfully than others
you